did want to do
if i may is turn to the threat posed by
the omicron varian which is obviously
incredibly relevant now i mean firstly
how significant of a threat does the
variant pose to public health in the uk
it's probably the most significant
threat we've had since the start of the
pandemic
and i'm sure for example that the
numbers that we see on data over the
next few days will be quite staggering
compared to
the rate of growth that we've seen in
cases for previous variants the real
potential risk here and i would
underline that because we are still
learning a lot about the variant is in
relation to its
severity clinical severity and therefore
whether those cases turn into
severe disease hospitalizations and
deaths and we are still at too early
stage for that in fact the world
probably is still at too early stage to
be clear
the difficulty is that the the growth of
this virus so it has a doubling time
doubling days at the moment which is
shortening i it's doubling faster
growing faster and in most regions in
the uk is now under two days
when it started we were estimating about
four or five so if you think of
that growth rate right across the uk and
we're starting to see it and feel it now
in london particularly but yesterday
particularly around manchester um and
we're very sure there are levels growing
across
most communities in the uk now although
there is quite a lot of regional
variation still the real the real risk
issue is that we can see that there are
so many unusual mutations on this virus
that it runs the risk of evading
our natural and or vaccine
immunity
and we have early studies looking at
immune serum from patients who've been
ill and been vaccinated to see that two
doses of vaccine
against symptomatic infections so we
don't know yet about severe disease but
about symptomatic infection is much
reduced
we do know that the booster dose will
push that right back up but it still
comes back to a level below that that
we've had with the booster effect for
delta our previous wave
and so this is highly significant
because the numbers of individuals who
are
potentially involved with this and a
small degree of vaccine or immune
evasion could have very significant
impact on our health services